je vois maintenant francis huster pour
duo pour violon seul aux côtés de sa
compagne cristiana reali sur la scène du
théâtre des variétés à huis clos dans
lequel il incarne le psy d'une virtuose
atteintes de sclérose et miné par la
névrose bref avec reali mystère zhu avec
passion sur nos cordes les plus
sensibles bonsoir bonsoir l'air très en
forme vous fumez toujours pas buvez pas
non mais parce que la chose en plus que
moi je dirai pas quel âge ça nous fait
plus d'un siècle à 2 ouais vous fait du
jogging ou filmer pas vous buvez pas
vous dormez pas beaucoup non je dors pas
beaucoup mais je balade le chien le
matin ce caramel et puis je joue au foot
le dimanche que le racing club de l'alma
et puis bon je sais pas c'est la passion
de tête mais bon j'ai bien servi j'ai
quand même ouvrage le livre est
peut-être que j'y pense bon alors
théâtre des variétés dont qui appartient
à notre ami jean paul belmondo duo pour
violon seul de tom collins qui mise en
scène de bernard murat en scène vous et
faites le cnra liez-vous donc l'histoire
comme on vient un petit peu de le dire
c'est un violeur une violoniste qui est
jeune célèbre riche qui apprend qu'elle
pourra plus jamais jouer de violon parce
qu'il est atteint de sclérose en plaques
et qui va voir un psychiatre et là
commence un duo duel en trois temps dans
un premier temps elle arrive assez forte
les tlc voilà ensuite lui lui dit oui
mais enfin quand même vous savez ce qui
vous arrive c'est quand même
mais en mer dans quoi et après c'est la
situation c'est ça qui est bien la
situation s'inverse et c'est finalement
elle qu'il remonte qu'il remonte lui
c'est ça ouais c'est exactement ça c'est
à dire que la pièce a toutes les
qualités du théâtre anglais américains
dans l'esprit c'est à dire que à la fois
c'est un sujet terrible terrifiant
puisque la sclérose en plaques il faut
le signaler c'est une maladie qui
attaque les centres nerveux et qui
entraîne une détérioration progressive
des muscles c'est irréversible c'est
incurable dit on mais en fait il ya un
combat personnel a menée et ça peut vous
laisser toute une vie vraiment et ce
qu'il ya d'extraordinaire dans la pièce
c'est qu'à partir de ce sujet terrible
il a écrit une comédie c'est à dire que
pendant les trois quarts de la pièce
tout d'un coup on hurle de rire tout
d'un coup tu y as well as été volés en
france
la pièce a été tourné au cinéma avec max
von sydow justement mais entre aux
jeunes à tulle et en inde mais ce qui
s'est passé ces cas à l'époque et à 20
ans elle a été jouée aussi par anny
duperey et roncq avait fait un triomphe
au montparnasse et ce qui s'est passé
c'est que aujourd'hui on peut jouer la
pièce tout à fait de façon différente
c'est à dire qu'avant c'était une pièce
comme un tremplin pour un numéro
d'acteur extraordinaire
et là c'est un tremplin pour un numéro
d'actrice évidemment le rôle est
toujours sublime et et on lui fait
l'ovation qu'elle mérite christiana mais
c'est aussi une pièce d'amour c'est à
dire c'est une pièce qui dit on peut pas
face à la maladie baisser les bras alors
on peut on peut rire on peut devenir il
s'est un peu plus et un peu plus
allenien disons qu'à l'époque aussi un
peu plus woody allen un peu plus new
york est un peu plus longue et bien sûr
c'est la deuxième fois qu'on travaille
avec bernard christiane avait travaillé
avec bernard sur la puce à l'oreille
avec jean-paul et puis moi j'avais
travaillé avec de l'eau et bernard
variations bon 2 on avait gardé des
souvenirs extension il a sorti la pièce
pendant la coupe du monde est venu vous
voir les venez nous voir étiez devant
vos matchs voulu entendre parler de rien
mais parfois moins du côté français et
christina des côtés brésiliennes
terrible à le couple
c'est terrible mais hey il a fait lire
la pièce à jean-paul et pas seulement
jean paul belmondo mais aussi paul
belmondo et alain belmondo et chacun
donc de générations différentes de de
vue différente
ils ont été complètement enthousiasmés
par ces pièces quoi alors murat a dit je
veux pas du ster que ça veut dire il
fallait que vous soyez sages que vous
soyez un peu en retrait ça veut dire que
et je lui tire mon chapeau
si bernard ça veut dire que il m'a
appris à ne plus jouer
il m'a appris à être au service de
l'autre dumas mais ça c'est le les
souvenirs de la comédie-française aussi
quand on quand on était en phase d ire
de charron un piano saigner un bon on
recevait en même temps et là je reçois
tous deux de christiana et puis aussi un
jeu totalement rentré quoi c'est vrai
j'ai dépassé la cinquantaine
slurp mais moi vous lui faites à elle
vous a fait questionner elle vous avez
un beau cadeau avec la petite elisa qui
est né au mois de mai mais vous lui
faites un beau cadeau aussi là parce que
comme vous la mettez en vous la mettez
en valeur là c'est très élégant ce que
vous faites
non franchement j'avais les doigts ça
use de sa paradoxalement j'ai jeudi sans
semblable à la pièce est un succès je
touche du bois
ça ça défonce tout mais pour moi je vous
assure vraiment entre deux entre deux
yeux c'est un des trois plus beaux rôles
de ma vie je des bandes parce qu'elle
vous a appris à vivre
christiania parce que vous êtes et vous
vous êtes un bosseur vous faites passer
votre temps à travailler ce qui fait
d'ailleurs vous avez finalement choisi
une compagne dans le métier qu avez-vous
joué ensemble comme ça vous pouvez
continuer à baisser un mail vous a
appris à vivre c'est très important de
ces les femmes nous apprennent toujours
la vie parce que nous on fait que
travailler mais elles nous apprennent le
plaisir et tout ça mais vous lui rendez
d'une certaine façon oui mais je crois
qu'elle m'a aussi appris la sincérité il
m'a de baratin pas des malades avoir
peur d'eux paradoxalement on croit
toujours que les femmes sont
quel sexe d'abord il ya le sexe il ya
l'amour il ya c'est à dire dans ses bras
il ya d'essayer la comprendre mais en
plus j'ai l'impression que par rapport à
une mère envers laquelle on est toujours
veux pas lui faire de peine réussir et
ou avec quelle jose prendre des risques
que j'aurais pas pris du poids vous
l'avez pas l'épouser toujours non ça
vous dit je veux pas l'épouser c'est une
raison markevich pas l'épouser d'abord
ce que la 20 ans de moins que moi ouais
c puis aussi parce qu'elle a un avenir
un peu comme l'un à venir un peu comme
adjani comme marceau comme binoche c'est
finalement ce serait peut-être un
handicap
oui j'en suis personnel c'est à dire que
je les pousse gelé tous pas pour moi je
les pousse tous les jours et dans la vie
et sur scène mais je pense que j'espère
qu'on avait un temps de bonheur devant
nous mais je veux qu'elle soit livré un
joli brasier mais paris son avenir c'est
l'avenir à l'arrêt alim
c'est grâce à ses pieds directement les
va vous disais dans une interview de 20
ans qui me restait lui bah oui je crois
parce qu'on le confond encore non non
français oui ben tant mieux j'espère un
certain regard en attendant la porte
garant mais ce que je vais dire ses 20
ans dans le métier quoi 20 ans à se
battre pour pour des trucs parce qu'on
voit des choix et on voit des tipis si
on le lui robert hirsch l'autre jour on
voit on voit les types en mes pieds plus
me parler mais qu'ils ont 80 ans
alors le fait qu'elle aime qu'elle aime
le théâtre ça doit aider parce que vous
êtes séparés d'isabelle adjani parce
qu'elle avait préféré le cinéma au
théâtre
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a le secret le
problème c'est sûr quand on quand on
choisit de faire une vie pour le théâtre
c'est qu'on rentre dans une vraie
famille
c'est un peu comme le foot quoi je sais
pas dans quel état sont les joueurs de
l'équipe de france séparés chacun dans
plein de clubs quand il se retrouve en
équipe de france mais mais pour moi ce
métier m'a tout appris et c'est vrai que
vivent avec la femme que j'aime la mère
que j'ai même bu ce qu'elle m'a donné
cette enfant elisa dans le théâtre ça
c'est extraordinaire
vous dites en même temps mais c'est
sympa un couple à la burton taylor comme
ceux les deux ans qu'on accepte pas qu
il n est pas sûr les journalistes je me
serais pas dit quand même si elle échoue
notre couple explosera donc c'était
important là ce qui se passe ici sur ces
thèmes
on sait que rencontre la pièce était
très important et je sais pas s'il est
parce qu est ce qu il faut savoir lever
risques en jouant avec vos tweets
totalement mais c'est pour ça que je
tire mon chapeau à bernard pour ce qu'il
a fait et artistiquement et à jean paul
belmondo parce qu'il ya jean paul il a
pris le risque de mettre au théâtre des
variétés une pièce comme ça justement et
et c'est grâce à lui et c'est vrai il
faut pas se mentir quand on est deux
acteurs si tout d'un coup il y en a un
des deux qui trouve pas la voix et tous
et en plus je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
metteurs en scène de cinéma puisque j'ai
eu la chance comme professeur chez
florent d'avoir toute cette génération
de chanteuses actrices berstheim
kiberlain de bayser christiane et enfin
bon tout le monde de cette génération là
chacune s'éparpiller plus ou moins et
elle elle a choisi ce nom
sinon il ya l'autre scénario c'est au
star is born quoi c'est dû dégâts lors
dé james mason ce qu elle beaucoup
succès travail égal ça se peut même et à
ce moment là un bon match et pas
j'écrirai on partira tous les deux se
faire des voyages mais justement parlé
du cours florent vous l'avez connu au
cours florent
alors florence est insensé parce que
françois florent avait convaincu vos
parents vous vous laissez faire du
théâtre j'avais pas c'est un type génial
florent fowler se voir un jour je vais y
aller la plus sage tout le monde croit
que françois florent gaillard ex ac
c'est un gars qui a six ans de plus ou
de nous et qui est extraordinaire qui a
une pêche folle je vais aller vite là
sur votre carrière parce que ça commence
maintenant ça quand même commencé en 70
donc comme un an 99
donc ce qu'il faut dire quand même parce
que tout le monde ne le sait pas trois
premiers prix au concours du
conservatoire ça c'était exceptionnel
comédie classique comédie moderne
théâtre étrangers et ensuite vous
explosez c'est très intéressant dans
trois disciplines en même temps ça vous
exploser dans jacques le fataliste au
théâtre pour delpech dans le monde j'ai
retrouvé fait un papier en 70 souidi
titré naissance d'un comédien retenez
bien ce nom quand même bon donc vous
exploser au théâtre exact le fataliste à
la télé avec les caprices de marianne et
au cinéma avec la faute de l'abbé mouret
franju et ensuite vous passer dix ans la
comédie-française dix ans avec renaud
barrault des gens et puis dix ans dans
le privé
et là vous commencez à dire il me faut
un théâtre et vous dit pas seulement il
me faut un théâtre vous dit sinon
j'aurais l'air c'est assez bien mais je
trouve ça bien
sinon j'aurais l'air d'être lafayette et
pas napoléon bon
vous avez dit c'est ouais moi tout ce
que je dis je le mentionne monsieur bien
vous avez dit aussi en 89 si je pense à
des rats napoléon s'ouvrit chose un jour
on reviendra en discutera de ça le pur
sang que c'est un peu comme de gaulle
c'est que je veux dire il ya deux de
gaulle il ya de napoléon il ya bonaparte
et napoléon qui est charles de gaulle il
ya le président de section vous dites en
89 si j'ai pas mon théâtre j'abandonne
la scène alors bon grâce à dieu je
dirais vous êtes toujours là vous avez
un moment failli avoir chaillot mais
comme savary avait soutenu mitterrand
élu a donné chaillot et vittel est allé
à la comédie française
quand michael devait partir vous deviez
reprendre la comédie française dont on a
parlé ici on a fait des débats où il y
avait plein de gens ici autour de cette
table qui disait et puis finalement bon
michael est resté vous pensez quoi alors
de la situation aujourd'hui bon vous
l'avez pas eu on vous souhaite tous
d'avoir un théâtre c'est vrai que
catherine trautmann vous a promis un
théâtre pour les demies oui c'est vrai
mais ça fait 20 ans en fait depuis la
sortie du français puisque j'ai suivi
mon administrateur pierre dux l
administration de jacques cha
ça fait 20 ans que et à la compagnie
renaud-barrault pendant dix ans et au
privé en fait j'ai cherché à bâtir ce
futur théâtre et je dois dire que la
troupe de la comédie française
moi j'ai vécu dix ans de bonheur fou
complètement fou extraordinaire d'où
leur état de choc à 220 millions
téléspectateurs en direct
la mise en scène et zeffirelli qui
allait les plus grands comédiens autour
de vous je veux simplement dire
simplement que la comédie française
c'est la plus belle troupe du monde et
que le travail qui a été fait et est un
travail difficile après la mort soudaine
de d'antoine vitez
il faut les respecter faut les défendre
faut comprendre leurs problèmes et je
suis sûr que ce soit moins que ce soit
un autre pour moi le principal c'est le
projet théâtral
qu'est ce que je suis ce que fait dans
le privé si ça se trouve on jouera ses
pièces trois ans cinq ans bon c'est quoi
la du départ subit de torreton
ah je pense qu il faut il ya toujours eu
des départs subite au bout de 10 ans il
ya eu qui a freiné au bout de 10 ans il
ya eu des tirs et qu'au personnel
retraité du français voilà c'est ça ben
philippe torreton que d'un acteur
formidable
aya une carrière totalement multiples
devant lui je pense que ce parti n'est
pas mort le seul le seul à qui ça a
coûté un peu de quitter la comédie
française c'est hirsch parce qu'après il
l'a dit lui même d'ailleurs il a il a eu
du mal
je crois que ceux qui ont eu tort de
partir du français ce sont ceux qui
justement en partant très jeune au bout
de 2 ans de 3 ans n'ont pas pu jouer le
rôle et n'ont jamais fumé
dites moi vous pompe à l'étal
impressionna qui vous a changé qui vous
a rendu peut-être un peu moins mégalo on
peut dire parce que c'est un reproche
que je me suis souvent adressées commun
souvent adressées par écrit son livre et
dans le papier dans le fameux papier de
poirot delpech cent soixante dix il
disait il dit beaucoup de bien de vous
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure mais il
disait il à un rien content de soi quand
même et puis vous avez cette espèce
d'ambition
vous vous disiez la même époque je ne
veux que des premiers rôles donc c'est
vrai qu'à un moment où peut-être aussi
vous avez un peu fatigués les gens avec
un côté un peu comme ça un peu bonaparte
au pont d'arcole parce que moi je
partage tout à fait ma vie c'est
simplement que c'était d'abord c'est le
fait de la jeunesse de merde va le
changer l'enthousiaste mairie et puis
surtout je bosse avec webber de red est
pour montrer notre état d'esprit à
l'époque que par les bears étions
ensemble et ça arrive le mois alors à la
rue blanche
un jour on avait foutu une affiche nous
sommes des génies avec marc on définit
on veut faire détruire en voulait se
battre mais bon on a eu beaucoup de
chance beaucoup de chance de rencontrer
des gens vous avez toujours la foi
aujourd'hui mais un peu moins la
mégalomanie ouais c'est ça on pourrait
dire mais je crois que le football m'a
beaucoup appris de ce côté là quand j'ai
vu quand je me pète la figure non c'est
pas la mégalomanie c'est le fait de
vouloir centrer dans un truc très
particulier comme un dingue qui tout
d'un coup se dit je veux faire le 100 m
je veux faire le 100 ma été par l'étoile
800 m et 7 cents triste à dire d'essayer
de votre vie au théâtre en fait parce
qu'on n'a pas à parler du cinéma mais
c'est vrai que vous avez un peu sacrifié
votre carrière au cinéma même si vous
avez fait des choses je voulais réaliser
un film de leur faire un autre mais
c'est vrai que j'ai quand même tout
donné
avec lui elle a tout donné au théâtre
parce que c'est une question de
génération je pense que faire du cinéma
à 60 ans comme par exemple michel
serrault sa carrière extraordinaire là
c'est une question d'emploi aux hippies
le théâtre c'est vrai il m'a tout donné
quoi je suis désolé on va s'arrêter là
voyez ça fait déjà dix sept minutes
conditions assez bien avec ça on perd
pas de temps donc voilà donc la pièce
s'appelle duo pour un violon seul set au
théâtre des variétés avec cristiana
reali et bien entendu francis huster et
allez-y c'est vraiment bien merci
beaucoup merci a bientot merci bien les
corrections de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'institut
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus